hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well near the end
of his treaties on the anger of God in
chapter 21 lock tonsius is going to
Grapple with some objections that will
inevitably be raised by some of his
fellow Christians having to do with God
being angry how can it be okay for God
to be angry when God has given
Christians precepts but I kepta
teachings about anger namely that
they're not supposed to be angry and so
he frames this as the question someone
will perhaps say God is so far from
being angry that in his precepts he even
forbids human beings to be angry so the
the general idea here is that God would
not command for human beings something
that God himself it's off whatever God
is would be engaging in because that
would be a kind of you know
contradiction or hypocrisy and you know
what verses or what teachings what
pricapta does lactances have in mind
well those found in The Sermon on the
Mount particularly in Matthew Chapter 5
where there's a very clear teaching with
three sort of uh you could say
increasing penalties for acts of anger
this is something that many Christian
theologians have focused in on and then
of course we have Ephesians where Paul
says you know be angry but don't sin
don't let the sun go down on your anger
try to avoid anger malice bitterness all
these sorts of things so it seems like
at least in scripture God is telling
people you really shouldn't be angry and
the way that lachtancius is going to to
approach this is by both differentiating
between the anger that God feels and is
moved by and the anger that human beings
feel and are moved by and he's going to
say that God doesn't actually rule out
all anger for human beings he rules out
the kinds of anger or the ways of
following and expressing anger that are
inherently problematic and so you know
he tells us first that human anger and
he uses several different
terms here needs to be
curbeda so you know sort of like
restrained pulled in break you could say
it also needs to be moderated temporary
artery so it's not getting rid of anger
completely it's keeping it within
certain
limits you could say within certain
boundaries a little bit later on he'll
tell us that you know anger is not to be
torn up by the roots but rather
restrained and corrected right so why
well because there's some really
important differences between human
anger and divine anger so the first
thing is that humans often get angry as
he says unjustly for wrong reasons he's
talked about this earlier in the piece
anger can be part of virtue but can also
be part of Vice for human beings and
there's a lot of ways in which our anger
goes wrong you know he he knows the
things that say the aristotelians and
the stoics and the epicureans have said
about human anger and he acknowledges
that insofar as they're describing
unjust anger they're they're actually
correct right they're correct in not
seeing that in God so he says
that because these things uh you know
should be done which the low and those
of moderate station and great Kings do
in their anger uh his rage ought to have
been moderated and suppressed
um you know less being out of his mind
he should commit some inexpiable crime
some crime that can't be remedied that's
that's us human beings so you know it's
not just the high it's also the the low
but God is never angry like he says
unless deservedly so you know it's it's
kind of a moot point God doesn't have to
rule out unjust anger for God because he
doesn't even do it for human beings
another key thing is that human anger
and here's very interesting thing to
point out human anger is as we can
translate it an immediate emotion price
symptom so something that happens right
away and he actually uses this term
twice throughout this chapter it's
something that we feel and then we're
immediately directed towards it as you
know other people pointed out there's a
certain
urgency towards anger and it's also a
temporary temporally and again he uses
this word twice in this emotion we can't
take anger as being a great guide for us
because it doesn't last all that long
actually when it does last too long it's
also a problem as he's going to say so
you know this is the case for us it's
not going to be the case case for God
however whose anger is as lactancius is
going to say in a certain way
Eternal and we'll come to that in just a
bit so there's some important
differences here and if that's not
convincing enough he's going to provide
some other arguments as well
so one of these is that and this is
quite ingenious God would be uh
condemning criticizing censoring
reprehensor you'd be a a Critic of his
own creation if he happened to prohibit
anger altogether in human beings right
because human beings are in fact like
everything else according to lactances
created by God so this you know raises
the issue of of evil is God responsible
for evil that has been addressed a
little bit earlier is God doing the
wrong thing by making it possible for
human beings to feel anger and
specifically now here we get to some
ancient medical ideas that we have you
know we don't we don't buy into anymore
they've been dismissed he says
he from the beginning inserted anger
into the liver of human beings because
it's believed that the cause of this
emotion is contained in the moisture of
the gall so this is dependent upon the
theory of humors which we don't accept
anymore but we could just as well you
know change this to say well why did God
give us brains that are subject to anger
why did he give us systems that like can
you know send cortisol and adrenaline
for our bodily system and it would be
the same question so you know he's
saying that if God prohibited anger he
would actually be condemning his own
work that doesn't make sense so he can't
be simply ruling out all anger with
these precepts which is the way that
some Christians have interpreted them so
he says well let's think about what God
is actually commanding in the precepts
so the first thing
is that we shouldn't be persevering in
anger in Europe
to stay for a extended duration in our
anger and why not well octancius says
things similar to what other Christians
point out and also other uh you know
pre-christian philosophers like for
example Aristotle when we remain in
Anger there is a tendency for that anger
to turn into something worse than anger
which is hatred treating people as
enemies
so that is a significant problem and
that's why we shouldn't be in you know
like remaining in Anger forever holding
grudges you know that sort of thing and
he says the anger of Mortals ought to be
mortal right and then he also says when
he had joined us to be angry and yet not
to sin right what does that mean we're
not tearing up anger by its roots but
restraining it so that we might preserve
two important things which are actually
ruling that anger moderation and even
more importantly Justice
lactances thinks that there are some
cases where we probably should be angry
but we need to remain within certain
boundaries that are imposed by
moderation and Justice two of the
cardinal virtues right
he also tells us that as human beings
and this is what the precepts are
requiring of us particularly that in you
know Matthew 5 where if you have a beef
with your brother you're not supposed to
bring your gift to the altar quite yet
just leave it there and be reconciled
and then come back Ephesians 4 Don't Let
the Sun Go Down Under your anger so we
should be appeased and notice that he
uses this term
placari right he doesn't say we should
forgive everybody he just says we should
be appease we should allow ourselves to
enter into this process of
reconciliation with our fellow human
beings and so this is what he's he's
saying God is actually telling us to do
about anger and then he's got a very
interesting discussion about the
temporality of divine anger he says I
had said the anger of God is not for a
time only
as is the case with a human being who
becomes inflamed with an immediate
excitement and on account of his Frailty
is unable easily to govern himself we
should understand that because God is
eternal
his anger also remains to
Eternity now that sounds pretty bad
right oh I've made God angry now I'm
screwed God will be angry at me for
eternity God actually you could say was
already angry at me for being the
screw-up that I am but he says because
he is endued with the greatest
Excellence he controls his anger and is
not ruled by it he regulates it
according to his will or rather he you
know does as he wills and then he says
if his anger had been altogether
Immortal now here's where he's you know
qualifying this idea of immortality or
eternality there would be no place after
a fault for satisfaction or kind feeling
though God commands human beings to be
reconciled before the setting of the Sun
so there would be a contradiction here
God is saying hey you human beings
forgive each other I'm not going to
forgive any of you bastards though
well it doesn't work like that the anger
remains against what it is that people
do wrong but if they change their ways
then they can be forgiven and the Divine
anger is directed at other things they
no longer fall under the Divine anger he
says that it does remain forever against
those who ever sin but those who you
know are going to change their ways the
anger won't be against them even though
there is eternal Divine anger so he says
God is Not appeased By incense or a
victim or costly offerings these things
are corruptable
what is he appears by a Reformation of
morals he who ceases to sin now notice
this this amazing line
renders the anger of God mortal
the one who
throws sin away who who withdraws from
that who changes their their character
makes the anger of God no longer Eternal
but mortal with respect to that right
not in general because it's not going to
redirect anger against those who God is
justly angry with the wrongdoers right
but it actually
um does change the situation of the
individual in relation to Divine anger
so lactancius is making sense of the
fact that God has given you know some
pretty clear and demanding precepts to
human beings about how they ought to
deal with their own anger and explain
why those precepts given by God don't
actually
vitiate God's own anger